hé monsieur la misère geez êtes-vous à la maison
ce sont des photos de notre salon
il y a cette chose je pense que c'est une caméra
aucun moyen mr.  B a inventé un appareil photo qui
prend des photos du futur l'appareil photo
crache une photo de nous dans le futur nous
passons notre journée à prendre une série de
décisions qui mènent jusqu'à ce moment
rappelez-vous comment mr.  B a pris une photo de
lui-même tenant une pancarte et si nous mettions
un journal si je combien d'argent nous pouvons
gagner allez Ron oui commencez juste à sourire
et dites au revoir à votre travail quotidien les gars
où est-ce que je ne sais pas prendre
dangereux quoi  est-ce qu'il fait dans l'
appartement il n'y a qu'une chose pire
qu'un gars qui ne peut pas la faire c'est un
gars qui ne perd jamais de sacs attends une seconde
non je vais faire ce que nous aurions dû faire
depuis le début je vais détruire ça
la machine bizarre
envoie cette récompense
aussi longtemps que nous nous voyons sur cette photo
tous les jours nous savons que nous vivons trop longtemps oh
vous avez dit que nous pouvons changer les choses correctement
tout s'est passé pour une raison
vous ne baisez pas le temps d'attente elle détruit ses
copines de machine  nous avons juste besoin de faire
confiance à ces bons
vous